hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the decline
variation
in the stafford gambit stafford gambit
coming from the petrov defense which
starts out with e4
e5 knight to f3 and then knight to f6
after white takes on e5 then black plays
knight to
c6 let's get this main line d6
kicking the knight back here to f3 get
that out of here
we're gonna play knight to c6 now i have
already made a video on the accepted
line
i'll have a link in the description
below if you want to check out that
video
also we'll have a link at the top of
this video if you want to check that out
at some point
but the main line would be for white to
take here on
c6 this is the best move for white only
if they really truly understand all the
theory on how they should perceive
because after black takes on c6
there's a lot of traps that y can fall
into you can see things are completely
open for black to start to attack
but white does not have to take here on
c6 that's what this video is going to be
going over the decline lines
a few variations that you could see from
white one is just pushing forward here
with d4 controlling the center of the
board and this knight here on e5
you could also see knight to f3 just
kicking the knight back says yeah
i got that pawn to material i was
already coming back here to f3
i just expected black to play d6 here so
they could just retreat back
to f3 and then the last option
would be pushing forward with f4
similar to the d4 this is just another
option much worse option than pushing
forward to d4 but you could see
something crazy
like f4 so we're going to look at that
as well
the first version we are going to look
at is if the pawn comes to
d4 controlling the center of the board
as well as this knight here on e5 and
then black's gonna play
queen to e7 now it looks like it's
attacking this knight it's actually
attacking this pawn here on e4 they have
a couple options they could take with
their
knights here on c6 and you can see uh
this
queen is attacking this pawn on e4 so
after it takes here this is
check they have a few ways that they
could defend this bishop
to e2 preparing to cast on the king side
black takes here on
c6 and this is kind of how the stafford
gambit
is looking to go for black anyway they
take here on
c6 they would have taken that out
earlier
if they just had the accepted line both
the bishops can get outside and start to
attack the opponent
black has options it can castle on the
queen side or the king's side
then from here maybe castle on the
king's side bishop to e6
you can see castle on the queen side
pretty easy there or you could get your
other dark square bishop involved into
the game now
they could also bring their other bishop
maybe bishop to
e3 same thing pawn takes here on
c6 if they played knight to c3 attacking
the queen then black can get the dark
shore bishop involvements of the game
pinning down the knight to the king
uh they would have to bring their bishop
back if they wanted to
get rid of that uh pin but you can see
that that is
pinned down by the queen so putting a
lot of pressure on them
so yes this is attacking the queen here
but they're going to have to get their
light square bishop out before they
castle on the king side so this is how
you would
approach it in that sense they could
also just do it with their queen
instead of the bishops blocking they
could just play queen to
e2 if that's case you could just take
with your queen after bishop takes
pawn to c6 taking the knight here
and this is a fine position bishop two
f5 attacking the pawn here on c2
preparing to castle on the queen side
uh you're not down in a material at all
so you offer up
a gambit if they decline it you're not
going down a material so you're usually
going to come to a place where both
sides are equal in material
and you definitely have a good board
presence
now after black played that queen to e7
if they don't take here on
c6 more than likely they're going to
play knight to c3 this knight's already
protected by the pawn so they don't have
to do anything
right away that's the case knight's
going to take on e5
the pawn has to take here on e5 and then
queen takes
e5 so you can see both sides down one
pawn
and one knight in material here if they
continue to push forward
uh f4 is really the best option for
white but man it just feels extremely
weird
to start pushing forward all this
material in front of the king because
black has so much material
involved into the action the queen's
gonna come back here to e6
would really like to stay active but
there's no good squares for the queen to
come to
uh now they could maybe push forward
with e5
which makes some sense attacking the
knight right here but now
black can just play bishop to b4 pinning
down
that knight they don't want to play
something like pawn two
f5 because then just the queen could
come back here to
e5 and this is the exact square that
black
wants to be now if they don't play f4
which i think is the best move for white
they could try
uh something else maybe bishop here to
d3 protects the pawn also prepares to
castle on
the king side of the board same thought
as before bishop to b4
pinning down this knight preparing to
castle on
the king side if they do castle i think
that's fine
you can just go ahead and take with your
bishop right here
and then if they recapture they have
double pawns here on
the c file and there's no pawns on
either the d
or the b file so that's really a
good position for black to be in now
white does have the bishop pair so that
is
what white is giving up for
having these double pawns here on the cd
file but i think this is a fine way to
continue
for black if they don't castle on the
king side maybe they play bishop to d2
trying to stop the pin right here
okay well now you can just push forward
with d5
trying to put more pressure on your
opponent i think this is a fine way to
continue
the next variation we are going to look
at is knight 2
f 3 just retreating in this case we're
going to go ahead and take that material
here on
e4 and they have a lot of options here
one option would just be to play
knight to c3 almost a reverse stafford
gambit that says
hey you tried to do this against us now
we're going to try to do it against you
you could take here on c3 but because
they declined
our gambits we are not going to give
them the
time of day and allow them to do their
shenanigans that we were trying to do so
instead we're going to push
forward with d5
now from here many times they will play
queen
to uh e2 this pins down the knights
and essentially they're setting up the
move uh d3
on our end we don't actually care at all
we're trying to get material involved
into the game so we're gonna play bishop
here to
b4 and then they play d3 guess what we
still don't care we're going to cast on
the king's head we're going to give up
that
that material here on e4 so they take
with their pawn
we're going to capture with our own pawn
here on e4
attacking this knight on f3 they're
usually going to bring it back here to
d2
this is the best move for white but now
is where things get interesting because
black has the move knight to
d4 starting to put a ton of pressure
on white
just to show you some of the pressure
that white is under the queen is under
attack right now
and they could try to bring their queen
out to c4 seems like a logical play this
is attacking both
this knight here on d4 as well as the
bishop here
on b4 but after the move
bishop to e6 this queen is actually
trapped
it's going to fall there's no way to
stop that
at all you can see this light square
diagonal can't go there
can't come here because it's going to
fall to the bishop can't come here it's
going to fall to the pawn
or the knight here it's going to fall to
the knight fall to the pawn right here
to the pawn and the knights right here
the only option is if it wants to
capture some material so it could take
here on b4
but now black has the move knight takes
here on
c2 forking the queen this is
check and so you after the king comes to
d1
then the queen is gonna fall here on b4
so the best move really for the queen
is to protect this square here on c1
or c2 because the thread of knight takes
here on c2
so white plays the move queen to d1
but the fun does not stop there for
black because you've
watched this video you will know how to
continue
always looking to get material involved
into the action that is the name of the
game with
most of the openings that we cover at
thechesswebsite.com so we're going to be
playing a bishop
to g4 now the first thing in any
move in chess you always want to be
looking at can i take that material did
my opponent make a blunder can i just
immediately take that you can see this
bishop here on g4
is unprotected we are asking
the queen to take this material here on
g4 yes this is absolutely what we are
looking to do
but one of the second things that you
should always be thinking about in chess
is what is the space left behind that
queen on d1 was protecting something
and that is the square here on c2 that's
exactly what black's looking to attack
here and that is knight takes here on c2
check
forking the rook here on a1 after king
to d1
knight takes here on a1 and then we
evaluate and try to figure out okay now
how do things continue from here now it
looks like the pawn here on e4
is free for the taking so queen takes
here on e4
but now the tricky move of rook to e8
now this attacks the queen but also it
just looks like white can continue to
gobble up material but it's not that
easy because if the queen takes here
on b4 then there's a nice little
deflection with
rook to e1 check the king can't come to
c2 because of the knight and so after
the king takes now the knight swings
back to c2
and we have a similar position as we
looked at before once the queen takes
here on b4
the knights on c2 forking this queen
and so we see the king come to d1 and
then the knight takes here
on b4
so as you can tell there's a lot to be
thinking about so many traps that y can
fall into
any time you're playing this stafford
game but accepted or decline lines maybe
they look at this and
they know that you're setting a trap
you're playing extremely fast here and
it seems like you know what's going on
so they may not take this bishop here on
a g4 maybe they see the threat of knight
takes here on
c2 and instead they they want to keep
their queen here so they play
knight to e2 okay well this kind of
stops all the
the immediate threats here but now all
of a sudden
black plays queen two h4 and just look
at the pressure that white is under
black is
for sure winning in this position uh has
king safety here
it's going to be very difficult for
white to cast on either side of the
board the king's in the center
both the bishops are eyeing down pinning
down these knights
see the only central pawn is from
black standpoint here on e4 can get both
the rooks here
very easy for black to find
continuations
and so this is going to be a very good
game for black a lot of attacking
lines here so always putting pressure on
your opponents
wanted to make sure that you understand
those lines
that was all if they tried sort of the
reverse stafford gambit honest after we
played that knight to e4
they played knight to c3 but they don't
have to do that they could just play
queen to e2 right away pinning down the
knights
preparing for that pawn to d3 move that
we talked about
we can just play queen to e7 it wouldn't
play the d5
in this position right here but now if
they play that d3 as we talked about
and i can come back to f6 that's fine if
they want to exchange material that's
fine we could take back bishop here to
e7
we plan on getting our dark square
bishop involved into the game anyway so
that would be completely fine
if they played knight to c3 pawn up here
to
uh d5 and we should have a very strong
game
the last variation we are going to look
at is with f4
not necessarily a good move but you may
see some crazy stuff in the stafford
game but decline lines we're going to go
ahead and take
here on e5 or reason they have the pawn
here is to protect it so they're going
to recapture
here and then we're going to take our
their pawn here on
e4 now they have a few options here
but the main threat that we have is
queen to
h4 so you know something like knight to
c3 where they may just be
immediately attacking it right here we
have the queen to
h4 so if they don't stop this threat
right away this
is what we are going to be playing and
from here maybe pawn to g3 doesn't
matter
knight takes pawn takes queen takes here
on g3 check
then we force the king out and then we
play pawn up here to d5
this is one of those places where they
probably
are going to have a tough time defending
against all the attacks we have
pawn to d5 opens up for the bishop to
come here to
g4 pinning down the king to the queen
uh the queen is going to fall on that
spot dark bishop
involved into the game you can see this
is going to be very difficult for
white to hold on to so i definitely
don't have to play knight to c3 just
showing you the threat that black has
here but they really need to stop that
but
the only way to stop that is something
like g3
okay that's an option but then we just
play uh d5
they probably don't want to on poisson
if you're not familiar they can take
here they have one
option one move to do this but this is
exactly what we want we're just going to
take back with our dirk square bishop
this opens things up for us while gets
another
piece involved into the action but maybe
they just play the
d3 um okay this is completely fine we
could just play
knight back here to uh g5 it's protected
by our queen here on
d8 so all in all i think this is going
to be completely
fine and you can see they probably don't
want to cast on the king side it's not
extremely safe if they want to cast on
the queen side they are going to have to
move three pieces before they
ever are able to do that uh so black can
start to look
and attack the king in the center of the
board so that is the stafford gambit
decline lines hopefully you enjoyed that
video again if you haven't watched the
accepted lines
definitely recommend checking that out
have a link in the description below
thank you so much for watching the video
if you have any comments about the
stafford gambit let me know
below if you have any other suggestions
for videos
also let me know in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching the
video
if you haven't already hit the like
button we appreciate that as well and
i'll see you guys
in the next video
you